[Caroline] Since we can't
travel in person,
we created "Share Your World,"
a show where fellow travel lovers
and I share experiences from
our cultural backgrounds.
In this episode, we're
saving room for desserts.
[Caroline] Some save it for
the end of the meal,
and others skip straight to it.
No matter how you enjoy them,
desserts are a sweet form
of comfort food served around the world.
My favorite Armenian dessert is Gata.
It's a sweet, round pastry.
And it's just really good
when you have it with tea,
or in the morning as breakfast,
or just a pastry on its own.
Also, with gata, sometimes the bakers
put a little coin in there,
and whoever gets the slice
with the coin is said to have good luck.
So I remember as a kid, I
would always eat so much,
just so I can get the coin
and I can get the good luck.
If you go to villages,
like Garni and Geghard,
those women over there
make it a certain way.
And they usually put Armenian letters
over it, or they write Geghard,
which is the place that they are from.
[Jason] So one of my
favorite Cambodian desserts
is sticky rice with
mango and coconut milk.
I actually went to Cambodia,
and my uncle owns a restaurant
where he actually made the dessert for me.
So, the mango is not your typical mango.
It's this long yellow mango,
as opposed to the green and red one.
And it's more like ovally-shaped
than the round circle.
When you eat foods that have
emotional connections to it,
I think it does taste better.
So every time I eat it now,
again, I remember my time in Cambodia.
[Kasey] So whenever I visit
Korea, the first thing I do is
I go get this dessert called patbingsu.
It's a shaved ice, it's about yea high.
They put condensed milk,
they put fruit pieces.
They put mochi rice cakes, red bean,
and you can get matcha
flavor, vanilla, hazelnut.
It's so refreshing and much,
much lighter than ice cream.
So the last time I went
to visit my parents,
I stayed at the JW
Marriott Hotel in Seoul.
And it's near this
neighborhood called Myeong-dong
And they just have all
these street vendors
late at night, and a ton of food options.
And there's a ton of shopping in the area.
So I will drag my parents
out at 11, midnight.
And we will go stop by all
the little street vendors.
And then for a dessert drink,
there's this sweet rice milk.
It's not thick at all.
So it's the consistency of lemonade.
And it's slightly sweet
and it's refreshing.
And it has little pieces of rice in it.
So then at the end, you kind of swirl it
so you can get all the rice chunks.
Even though I like to
buy the sweet rice drink,
I always want my mom to
make a whole batch as well.
So I'll use my Marriott
Bonvoy Boundless™ Card
to earn points by buying
all the ingredients.
So it's so beneficial because I'm
spending it on the card,
but also earning points.
So I just feel like it all
works out great, having this card.
I will travel anywhere just
to try all the best desserts,
the best snacks, the best meals.
I'm all about it.
You know, to me, food is also art.
[Katrina] I'm with you on that.
Plus one on the foodie, I
will travel for food as well.
[Debby] Honestly, when I was younger,
my biggest dream was
working in a Swiss bakery
because I just love every bit
of pastry that we have back home.
And when you go to a Swiss bakery
the way they present it, it's
just absolutely beautiful.
Two of my favorite pastries, which,
I mean you have it here
in America as well,
it's carrot cake and a Black Forest cake.
We can buy it here in America,
but it's just obviously
not the same recipe.
It's different back home.
So the chocolate that's on
top of the Black Forest cake
in Switzerland is just this
very thinly sliced chocolate,
and inside the Black Forest
cake, there's dark cherries.
And I think here in America
a lot of times it's the
bright red cherries.
They're just softer and they
have a much richer taste to it.
The carrot cake back home is really
just the cake base with carrots in it.
And then the top is a sugary glaze
that you make yourself,
you can add some lemon to it for flavor.
And then we actually have
little carrot shaped marzipans
that we decorate it with.
I literally can't get enough of it.
So whenever I go to Switzerland,
you bet I'm gonna eat those things.
[Caroline] Yeah, like with Switzerland,
you know you're gonna try chocolate,
but no one told me I should
try the carrot cake too.
[Debby] Yeah because as I said,
in America you know carrot cake.
So it's not something that you would
necessarily try in a different country,
because it's not specific to Switzerland.
It's just the way that
we make it is different.
We're surrounded by a bunch of countries.
There's Germany, there's
France, there's Italy.
It's a very small country,
but very, very international.
So we do like to borrow ideas
and recipes from our
surrounding countries.
[Caroline] I am so hungry
after our conversation.
I definitely learned a lot.
And I can't wait to try
everything that we talked about.
If you got a sweet tooth
from watching this video,
we hope you're inspired to start planning
your next dessert-filled adventure.